in mindset we talk about fixed mindset
yeah and we talk about an open and
growth mindset and the thing is we're
all built up of them two things but what
I realize is I notice when I'm in the
fix I think whoa what am I doing I need
to flip what I've just thought then
because it's going against it I really
am sometimes like everyone thinks can I
do this I don't know if I'm good enough
it was just a fart in my head just a
thought what happens if I just change
what I thought like it's the way the
thinking when things happen if yesterday
was a setback we'd bring the setback
with them and when you're in a negative
mindset it's like the Law of Attraction
like we attract things to us when we're
thinking negatively we're acting
negative our actions are negative our
behaviors are negative people who want
to be top Billy want to be top Builder
because they're willing to do anything
to be top biller whatever change you
need to make they'll make it whatever
thing they need to learn to learn it
they'll follow it they'll turn up on
time they'll do the timings they'll work
extra it's like it's their actions